es útil hacer una función invertible a
partir de una que no es invertible al
restringir su dominio la gráfica de fx
se muestra a continuación es esta de
aquí a qué intervalos podríamos
restringir fx para obtener una función
invertible y bueno es que recuerda que
cuando buscamos una función invertible
la relación inversa tiene que ser una
función bien definida a qué me refiero
con eso bueno primeramente déjame
mostrarte que esta es una función que no
es invertible y hay varias maneras de
hacer eso lo primero es que efe esta
función es una función de una manera
clara si nosotros nos fijamos en la
prueba de la recta vertical si yo por
ejemplo aquí trazo una recta vertical
aunque se vea más o menos así me tomo
una recta vertical más o menos como ésta
ésta de aquí va a ser mi recta vertical
ok entonces date cuenta que se
intercepta solamente en un
en este punto de aquí y es más déjame
cambiar a un color un poco más fuerte
para que lo veas una manera más clara en
este caso esta recta vertical y es más
dejen hacerlo así esta recta vertical
intersecta a la función en sólo un punto
en este punto de aquí ahora ten cuidado
seguramente te estás preguntando por qué
esto nos ayuda a ver que esta es una
función pero es que imagínate que no
interceptara en sólo un punto imagínate
que tuviéramos algo así una función que
baja y aquí otra vez va a tomar un
cierto valor va a bajar o no espera
déjame cambiar de herramienta y entonces
va a tomar un cierto valor para esto así
y se ve como una relación como esta
bueno pues date cuenta que en este
momento la recta vertical toca a dos
puntos pero como está tocando a dos
puntos entonces qué pasa para esta x que
tenemos aquí para x igual a 7 para x
igual a 7 cuál es su valor es 3 su valor
o es menos 3 su valor
en este momento no estamos mapeando a
esta x a un único valor y por lo tanto
no sabríamos cuánto vale el valor de x
igual a 7 lo cual como sabemos no es una
función y es por eso que nos sirve la
prueba de la recta vertical para saber
si esta gráfica es una función pero
bueno déjame quitar todo esto porque
ahora vamos a utilizar la prueba de la
recta ya no vertical sino en este caso
va a utilizar la prueba de la recta
horizontal y esto nos va a servir para
ver si la función es invertible la
prueba de la recta horizontal nos va a
servir para ver si la función es
invertirle o no
y es que una forma de ver esto es que
vamos a intercambiar los valores de x y
de bien porque entonces la gráfica de la
función se vería más o menos así si los
intercambiamos
imagínate que esto lo voy a voltear y me
va a quedar
algo así y voy a pasar x
a este punto voy a pasar por este punto
y entonces me quedaría algo más o menos
así ok y después aquí empezaríamos en
este y vamos a pasar por este punto y me
quedaría algo más o menos así aunque
ésta sería intercambiar los valores de x
por los valores de james y bueno aquí
justo en este valor tomaría este punto y
entonces si yo me regreso 1234 aquí aquí
empezaría y pasaría algo más o menos así
y bueno de igual manera para camps aquí
tomaría este valor y entonces antes yo
me regreso 4 entonces va a ser algo más
o menos así así se vería
intercambiaremos los valores pero date
cuenta que en este caso no pasa de una
manera clara la prueba de la recta
vertical si te das cuenta en este
momento tenemos una recta vertical y
tocamos muchos valores tocamos este
valor de aquí este valor de aquí este
valor de aquí y este valor de aquí y por
lo tanto
no estamos pasando la prueba de la recta
vertical ahora otra forma de verlo sería
desde un principio aplicar la prueba de
la recta pero en este caso me voy a
tomar la recta horizontal en este caso
no voy a tomar la recta horizontal y se
vería más o menos así si yo me fijo en
una recta horizontal por aquí por
ejemplo date cuenta que tocamos a varios
puntos tocamos y déjame poner con este
color a este punto de aquí a este punto
de aquí a este punto de aquí a este
punto de aquí y entonces estamos
hablando de una función que no es
invertible nuestra prueba de la recta
horizontal claramente está fallando y
una vez más porque esto prueba que no es
invertible bueno porque estamos
interceptando a la recta en varios
puntos y porque esto es un problema
bueno recordemos un poco que debería de
cumplir una función y su función de
inversa si yo tengo por ejemplo aquí
vamos a ponerlo justo aquí tengo
y el dominio de esta función y déjame
ponerlo así aquí tengo el dominio
dominio ok y por acá me voy a tomar el
dominio por acá no voy a tomar alcohol
dominium o dominio
bueno pues date cuenta de lo siguiente
si yo me tomo el valor de 4 me da el
valor de 4 así que si tiene el dominio
me tomo el valor de 4 bueno pues después
de aplicar la función f de 4 me va a dar
4 en este caso en la función mapea al 4
al 4 esto en la función ahora si yo me
tomo por ejemplo el 9 el 9 también lo
mapea al 4 por lo tanto lo voy a poner
así
efe de 9 bueno después de que apliquemos
la función me da también 4 de lujo
ahora si nosotros pensamos en la
relación inversa que es lo que va a
pasar recuerda que la función inversa va
a tomar elementos del co dominio y los
va a mapear con elementos del dominio
pero en este caso cuánto valdría f
inversa de 4 cuanto va el día efe
inversa de 4 valdría 4 nos regresaríamos
al valor de 4 o en su dado caso
efe inversa de 4 norma y regresaría en
este caso al 9 a cuál de los dos valores
voy a dar y es justo el problema
efe inversa no sabemos si me regresa al
no sabemos si me regresa al 4 o en su
dado caso me regresa al 9 y por lo tanto
estamos encontrando un grave problema
una relación que no va uno a uno y este
es justo el problema cuando tenemos
varios elementos del dominio que se
mapean a un mismo elemento del dominio
esto está bien en un principio para
hacer una función
elemento del dominio lo mapea a un
elemento del condominio pero ahora esto
nos va a traer un problema para que la
relación de inversa
sea una función y en este caso nos da
una función que no es invertible así que
esencialmente lo que vamos a hacer es
averiguar en qué intervalo podemos
restringir la función para obtener una
función invertible estos intervalos
deben de pasar la prueba de la recta
horizontal para cada miembro del
intervalo que nos vamos a tomar se deben
de cumplir que todos sus valores se
maten a valores distintos de su co
dominio un mapeo uno a uno entre los
miembros del dominio restringido y del
potencial o de un niño restringido así
que veamos estos distintos dominios
restringidos para ver qué es lo que pasa
qué te parece si empezamos con el
primero menos 10 0 y es un intervalo
abierto así que menos 10 está como por
aquí tenemos un intervalo abierto déjame
cambiar de color y es más déjame limpiar
esto para que podamos trabajar en
vamos a quitar esto de aquí ok entonces
déjame tomar otro color este color de
clic aquí va a empezar un intervalo está
abierto y vamos hasta el 0 y si te das
cuenta justo aquí no pasa la prueba de
la recta vertical por ejemplo aquí
tomamos un valor
para james dos veces aquí y acá y por lo
tanto aunque este intervalo parecía ser
un buen intervalo no es un intervalo en
el cual podemos restringir la función
para obtener una función invertible ya
que tenemos valores repetidos para ello
para algunos valores para x por ejemplo
aquí menos 9 y 2 y aquí menos 4 y 2 por
lo tanto este en definitiva no pasa la
prueba de la recta horizontal veamos
este otro menos 10,5 abierto todos los
intervalos son abiertos así que vamos a
ver este otro dejar quitar esto de aquí
vamos a quitar esto de aquí y vamos a
ver el siguiente menos diez menos cinco
menos diez como menos 5
y es un intervalo abierto así que vamos
a ponerlo así menos 10 está abierto
menos 5 está también abierto y si te das
cuenta este intervalo se cumple porque
si nos fijamos aquí cualquier recta
horizontal que nos tomemos solamente va
a tocar a un punto en esta gráfica
cualquier recta horizontal que nos
tomemos solamente va a tocar a un único
punto en esta gráfica y esto es porque
tenemos un intervalo abierto más y que
no puede vamos a tocar este punto
tenemos desde aquí hasta acá todos los
valores y además porque esta gráfica si
es invertible este pedazo de gráfica si
es invertible 10 más lo podemos
visualizar de la siguiente manera si
nosotros nos fijamos en esta función de
aquí y ahora me tomo la función inversa
bueno pues date cuenta que ahora voy a
estar en el punto menos 10 0 lo voy a
pasar al 0 como al menos 10 al 0 como
menos 10 estaría por aquí pero lo voy a
poner abierto y aquí en el 5 en el menos
50 lo voy a pasar al cero
al menos 5 aquí voy a tener un intervalo
abierto y bueno aquí cerca en el menos
64 lo voy a pasar al 4 menos 6 algo más
o menos por aquí y por aquí va a pasar
mi función inversa se vería más o menos
algo así que si te das cuenta no es ni
más ni menos que una reflexión bajo la
recta y igual a equis si nos tomamos la
recta
x date cuenta que en este momento este
pedazo de gráfica es una reflexión de
este pedazo de gráfica y por eso si
podemos encontrar la función inversa en
ese intervalo abierto por lo tanto voy a
poner que si es de valdo si funciona y
entonces le voy a poner una palomita y
le voy a poner una pequeña paloma porque
recuerda que pasó la prueba de la recta
vertical ahora veamos el siguiente
intervalo menos nueve coma menos cuatro
menos nueve está aquí abierto menos
cuatro está aquí abierto y si te das
cuenta
este también es un intervalo que nos va
a servir déjenme borrar aquí todo esto
para que lo veas con mayor claridad si
yo por todo esto ok
vamos a ver si pasa nuestra prueba de la
recta vertical -9 el -9 está por aquí lo
voy a poner abierto -4 está aquí lo voy
a poner abierto y si te das cuenta en
este intervalo cualquier recta que yo me
tomé a horizontal
solamente va a tocar a un punto este
toca a estos puntos de aquí estas rectas
y después llega un punto en el que
empieza a tocar a la función en estos
puntos de aquí en estos puntos aquí a
este también le voy a poner una pequeña
paloma este también nos sirve vamos a
borrar todo esto de aquí ok y ahora
vamos a aplicarnos en el intervalo menos
10 como a menos cuatro menos diez que
está justo por aquí a menos cuatro
estaba justo por aquí y éste en
definitiva no pasa esta prueba porque si
te das cuenta
aquí estoy encontrando una recta
horizontal que toca dos de los puntos
por lo tanto éste
y no nos va a servir y ahora vamos a
fijarnos en el último intervalo menos 50
entonces deje a meditar esto de aquí y
me voy a aplicar en el menos 50 si te
das cuenta el menos 5 está justo por
aquí tenemos este punto es un intervalo
abierto el 0 tenemos este punto su
intervalo abierto y si te das cuenta si
yo trazo cualquier recta horizontal por
aquí este si funciona es decir cumple la
prueba de la recta horizontal y por lo
tanto lo voy a marcar como una opción
correcta porque ya pasó nuestra prueba y
ya está